make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
okay so as promised we are getting into
Dark Phoenix in time for the movie's
release so again like like what we
talked about in the previous video when
we cover the Phoenix saga is that there
are some things that take place between
the Phoenix and Dark Phoenix artists but
the weird thing is that is kind of hit
and miss right I guess it's the the
nature of the beast and so because that
were actually gonna kind of go back and
hit on some of the finer points before I
guess as we go through this story or at
least the first part of it um and then
we'll kind of pick up with the Grand
Poobah Vince and the arrival of the Dark
Phoenix and all that kind of good stuff
so um initially what you know really
when it comes to the Dark Phoenix saga
this runs between uncanny x-men issues
129 and 138 um but the the brunt of all
the stuff really kind of happens in a
later bit and so with this beginning
part right here we initially pick up
with like banshee and and Cyclops and
Jean as well as more mchte habit now
there were a couple of things that went
on here um and really a couple reasons
why this is being done the way that it
is so banshee as we know is Shaun
Cassidy he basically has the ability to
emit kind of a sonic scream not really
on the same level as Black Bolt
of the Inhumans uh his scream can do
anything between like you know shadow
rocks and allow them to fly to mountains
different things like that but as my no
means like planet-destroying ah but the
idea behind this is that are really in a
couple issues running up to this we
ended up dealing with a villain named
Proteus now Proteus is kevin McTaggart
who's actually the son of a guy named
joe and and more on McTaggart herself
the way this played out was that kevin's
powers is or really has a power to
manipulate reality but only on a limited
space so imagine if like Franklin
Richards of the Fantastic Four the son
of Reed Richards could only manipulate
reality within like I don't know like a
one-mile sphere of himself or something
like that um that's basically what
Proteus did he can do anything but just
within that limited space but because
his powers are so extreme and because
it's how nobody really knew how to
handle him he was essentially kind of
locked away for a time now this ended up
resulting in like some crazy pirate guy
some boat guy who is a dick uh who just
had problems with war McTaggart showing
up on the doorstep and like breaking
into their home and then as soon as that
happened he ended up freeing Proteus by
accident and then and then Proteus
basically took over the guy's body right
because when it comes to Kevin because
his powers are so extreme the human body
can't handle them now this is something
I want to talk about for a second
because this is not something you really
see anymore in Marvel Comics
back in the 1970s 80s and even in the
early 90s you had such a thing as powers
that were so extreme that a normal human
body couldn't handle them and this is
really a way for a writer do
essentially create a villain or hero and
then kind of transcend them from the
human element and then move them into a
much greater thing right to basically
say they can always make their return
Apocalypse was like that Proteus was
like that the original x-men maigre was
like that the problem is model never
brought him back and when they did he
basically came back as Jesus in a story
actually no one's reading right now but
with this tidbit here Proteus is just a
character whose powers are wildly
extreme now ultimately because of the
fact that he has these sort of energy
bonds more or less metal disrupts that
and so it eventually came down like
Colossus along with a couple x-men who
ended up defeating him and it was
believed he was dead now he's not but at
the time this story was being written
it's believed that Proteus was dead and
so what this did is it allowed Chris
Claremont to kind of write out Banshee
and more McTaggart not in the sense
he'll never see them again but at the
same time this was going on you had
black Tom Cassidy who's related to
Banshee and was actually raising Teresa
siren who's the daughter of Banshee and
so because that it kind of a lot of
Claremont to sort of go into that story
arc and keep the two of them somewhat
removed I mean again Banshee was kind of
hitting this but more Mike Haggard had
also kind of tie into like the New
Mutants and all that kind of good stuff
so again there was a lot leading up to
this in terms of what came out of the
Phoenix saga and the Dark Phoenix saga
now this is when we really start getting
into it into the Dark Phoenix in the
events that lead up to that
when the exit is kind of taken off and
heading back to the e to the X Men
mansion and then suddenly Jean Grey is
basically psychically assaulted by not
really assaulted but like psychically
bombarded by jason wyngarde
now jason wyngarde is not new here jason
wyngarde has been around for a long long
time in fact he was part of Magneto's
original Brotherhood of Evil Mutants
which faced off against the x-men in
issue number four I think it was by Stan
Lee and Jack Kirby and so when this when
this happens jason wyngarde has found
success as part of a group called the
Hellfire Club now the Hellfire Club
exists in two forms
you have the Hellfire Club itself and
then you have the inner circle the
actual Hellfire Club is more of a front
right whether does the super wealthy
well-to-do organization but the inner
circle basically exists to just kind of
collect power as much as they can as
much power as they can right so like
they influence governments the influence
company is the only company they haven't
really been able to gain a foothold in I
think it's rocks on oil but outside of
that they influence almost everybody but
when it was when it was realized by Emma
Frost who will actually pick up with
here in a minute but when it was
realized by her that Jean Grey was the
Phoenix and possessed an insane amount
of power then it became we can bend her
to our will and so because jason
wyngarde has the power to manipulate the
five-cent
and make you believe that everything
that you're seeing touch a seeing
touching tasting hearing and smelling is
absolutely real then what they could do
is use him as a means to ensnare Jean
Grey their problem with this is you're
talking about a being with the power of
a god right so it's like if jason
wyngarde tried to use his powers on
Galactus by himself
it wouldn't work and so a device was
created by Emma Frost that would
basically amplify the power of jason
wyngarde and when in turn allow him to
ensnare Jean and that's what happens now
this is one of the big things that kind
of comes out of this is its little bit
by little bit right if he just like
full-on psychically assaulted Jean then
like it wouldn't work right because she
would have immediately picked up that
something was wrong and then it would
have just you know it all would have
gone belly up for the Hellfire Club
instead it's bit by bit it's small
moment here small moment there if these
little glimpses right like these small
little moments where jason wyngarde well
basically like twitter mind into
believing that she's on like a
victorian-era ship and like the two of
them are lovers and like Cyclops is just
some goofball who's trying to get in the
way and like that's it and for her she
believes it's 100% true now there's two
forces operating here right I mean
there's two forces that are going on
here the first of course is Jean herself
who's easily and snared for the second
is the Phoenix who could block all that
from jeans but it's curious and so
that's why these things really work in
in conjunction with what it is that
Jason wind guards trying to do and so
again that's when we start to pick up
with like the introduction of Kitty
Pryde which again it's kind of a small
little thing and that's the nature of
Claremont stories right I mean Kitty
Pryde kind of gets introduced here and
she's brought into the x-men ah but
that's basically yet it's just kind of
like here's a future member of the team
ah that's the way Claremont did think
try Claire I would introduce a character
and then give them a huge moment right
Laurie where Kitty Prada gets introduced
here ah in like three issues after the
events of Dark Phoenix saga Days of
Future past kicks up so she immediately
gets a great big huge role in Days of
Future past so it goes on to show that
she will become a significant member of
the x-men
that's how climb on did things so so
with with this particular event of
course she's being recruited by both
Emma Frost as part of the Massachusetts
Academy and then Xavier is part of the
school for gifted youngsters now with
Emma Frost and the Massachusetts Academy
that will eventually become home to the
Hellions which is basically Emma Frost's
own variation of like the New Mutants
slash you know x-men kind of an
amalgamation of those eventually all the
Hellyer's would be massacred then she'll
end up leaving and becoming a good guy
but at the at the outset here in this
moment she's kind of a rival to a degree
to Charles Xavier school for gifted
youngsters but she's really raising like
villains more so than she's like raising
chrome or raising heroes and that makes
any sense
it's just one of the many things that
kind of went into in the Clairemont
riding that like there's a lot of things
kind of going on here and so what this
does is it leads to Emma Frost and the
Hellfire Club basically going through in
capturing the x-men and they managed to
pull it off quite readily now that's
another another important thing to bear
in mind is that with the Hellfire Club
they almost never go into anything blind
rightly they almost never go in having
no idea what's going on or how to win
and so with Emma Frost leading the
charge is like one of the most powerful
telepaths in the world and depending on
what story arc you're reading sometimes
more powerful than Charles Xavier we saw
that in Civil War the the idea behind
this is that like using all the
information they have on how the x-men
work and how they function they end up
taking a Colossus storm and animals rain
now of course again this Lisa leaves an
opening for Kitty Pryde to basically
join in and then kind of say hey look I
can help rescue the x-men and and prove
my worth but again it's kind of bouncing
back and forth here small little moments
here and there little tidbits and so
getting a bit of a reprieve this is when
things really start to get interesting
it's getting a bit of a reprieve and and
kind of going on and doing a bit to sort
of spend time among themselves as well
as investigate what's basically the
Hellfire Club you end up having Jean
Grey and Scott Summers who go to a local
bar or local disco as it's called which
is actually of the headlining act is
dazzle which is kind of interesting she
can manipulate light basically but with
the two of them going through there of
course there immediately and unbarred by
jason wyngarde again at least Jean is
and so with this kind of going down this
whole scenario plays out where like
jason wyngarde shows up and says hey
like you remember each other we were
lovers all that kind of good stuff
any kind of again being teleported back
into the moment Jean Grey just sort of
says yeah like I mean I remember you you
know we're definitely lovers and the two
of them actually end up getting married
and she basically kind of goes forward
as what seems to sort of be this
villainous version of herself or at
least jason wyngarde kind of pulls her
in and sends her that direction now
that's the motivation of winGuard
right I mean we kind of haven't made
that clear this moment that's the
motivation of Wingard that in in the
mind of Jason everybody kind of has the
devil inside them right you know it's
it's the the aspect of themselves that's
looking to cut loose and just sort of
break all the rules right I mean it's
bad boys and bad girls you know they
kind of realized that this some rules
can be bent others can be broken to
quote the matrix with this being the
case with jason wyngarde playing on gene
what he's looking to do is unlock the
darker side of her right the part that
is kind of wants to spin out and just do
whatever is she wants to do because then
what the Hellfire Club can do is indulge
those desires which you know to create
you know havoc and to tear down or
whatever is they want to do I can use
her as a means to kind of take over the
world more or less the problem with this
is that again where she's having a
mental flashback keep in mind that is
only her mind that's experiencing this
she's not physically being transported
into the past to a victorian-era
landscape and so in this moment were
Jason wind guards there and he goes to
kiss Jean she doesn't in front of
Cyclops and that's when psychology
Ginn's to realize okay something's
actually wrong here now of course
Cyclops doesn't necessarily bail out on
her although he's very close to doing it
but at the time that all begins to
happen of course the Hellfire Club makes
their move attacking Jean attacking
Cyclops and in Dazzler as well now again
Dowler's introduction here is just kind
of hey look I can manipulate you lights
and stuff like that I don't know that
I'm a mutant they basically you know
Cyclops says yes you are and you have
these powers you should come hang out
with us and so on and so forth it all
kind of wraps up pretty fast we're like
it's not super it's not super intense
but again focusing on on Jean focusing
on the Hellfire Club that's when they
begin to kind of ask the question okay
what's going on here like like what's
happening with Jean and it's kind of
interesting because Jean Jean doesn't
necessarily tell Cyclops what's going on
and that's kind of interesting here
right because what she is experiencing
is what's essentially an affair right I
mean like what kind of goes on here is
actually almost what went on or almost
identical to what went on with with
Grant Morrison's new x-men right we're
like Cyclops engages in a psychic affair
with Emma Frost and the two of them
actually sleep together in Cyclops is
mine and then Jean Grey kind of walks in
but in in this particular situation
she's not telling him when she's not
like yeah there's this guy who's like
psychically assaulting my mind and like
tricking me into believing that I'm in
like you know a victorian-era landscape
or something like that because not even
Jean fully feel it fully realizes what
she's going on and there's actually kind
of an emotional attachment there right
like what jeans basically doing is she
spent her whole life with like the Boy
Scout the guy who never breaks the rules
always does the right thing so on and so
forth and that's cool I guess
but then now she's basically kinda got
kind of like this bad boy in her life
right like like I can take you away from
like this boring life that you live and
bring you into something better and she
kind of wants to take it but again it's
one part Jean who's sort of swept up in
this emotional turmoil and then it's the
Phoenix that's sort of feeding on it
right so even if Jean wanted to walk
away she probably couldn't now of course
you've also got Emma Frost who's
basically defeating I'm sorry who's
who's capture the other x-men and then
you've got you know Kitty Pryde who kind
of sneaks in and basically freeze like
Wolverine which in turn goes through and
allows Wolverine to free everybody else
and then you have the
the x-men who arrived on the scene all
of whom end up you know doing battle
with Emma Frost but this is kind of cool
because this is really where jean begins
to shift right like this where she
begins to move away from me from the
superhero that we knew her as and starts
to kind of lightly indulge in her darker
side which basically confirms to jason
wyngarde that what he's doing is working
she ends up getting into a psychic
battle of sorts with Emma Frost and
where the other x-men are freeing each
other and they're trying to make their
escape and so on and so forth Jean
actually kind of all-out assaults Emma
and almost like destroys her mind in the
process now under normal circumstances
and coming out of the Phoenix saga when
when that event ended and Jean realized
the full totality of the power she
possessed and what she could do with it
she put these blocks in place right
she's like okay there's a huge amount of
power here but I'm going to restrain
myself so that I never lose control
because if I do god only knows what
could happen I could wipe out the earth
and the entire solar system presumably
the entire galaxy I'm in possession of
an infinite source of power from like
across the omniverse so like I can't
just let things go and do whatever it is
that I want to do but in this moment in
this fight with Emma Jean doesn't here
she just lets loose and when that
happens like it almost completely
eradicate and kills Emma Frost and
that's one of the things that Cyclops
picks up on he starts talking to storm
he's like hey look I don't know if you
noticed but like with Jean Grey she is
pretty dangerous now like she's really
kind of snapping and losing control and
we have to be aware of what's going on
and so in response to this and really
kind of as a follow up the x-men begin
investigating the Hellfire Club where
they kind of go in there and say okay we
have to figure out what's happening
and it's kind of a funny moment here
right because like as soon as they get
in there jason wyngarde strikes again
and when that happens like Jean Grey is
totally ensnared right like it's the
last fig leaf right it's the last thing
Jean Grey is now no longer in a mindset
where she's in love with Cyclops she's
totally in snared by jason wyngarde now
she sees jason wyngarde as he wants to
be seen and so when she when he ends up
leading her away it's kind of crazy
because like he has I've taken her
upstairs and it's like okay Cyclops so
like some guy basically just like
grabbed your girl and she's going
upstairs with him now you got one of two
choices man you can be a punk and just
be like well I mean I guess she really
likes him or you can go up there and get
your girl and that's that's exactly what
you need to do man you gonna let another
man walk off with your woman then you
didn't deserve to have her in the first
place man you gotta fight for the things
you love folks sometimes you get beat up
sometimes you get a
guys sometimes you get all kinds of
messed up we just fight for the things
that you care for fight for the things
that matter to you and Cyclops does the
problem is that Cyclops is a punk no
he's not but actually the problem is
that Cyclops is facing the power of a
god that's the problem the Cyclops has
and so like when he goes running up on
Jean she completely blasts him with like
a huge portion of the Phoenix's energy
now if not enough to kill him right but
like at this moment is when the rest of
the Hellfire Club make their move right
because the x-men respond the Hellfire
Club responds back and that's what we
start to get like these really cool
explanations on what the various members
can do so beginning with Sebastian Shaw
Sebastian Shaw is a guy who can
essentially absorb an unlimited amount
of energy kinetic or I guess you know
integral really any kind of energy and
then up and then like channel it into
like physical strength right so for
those of you guys who remember um knocks
from heroes the black guy think of him
except instead of fear he could absorb
just like you know physical energy right
so like physical punches blast that
aren't powerful enough to like destroy
his physical body and it turns into
physical strength it amps him up and so
really it's it's very difficult to
destroy him who would take somebody with
an extreme level of power to destroy
Sebastian Shaw again it's only physical
strengths like what you saw in x-men
first class I think it was with a Kevin
Bacon Sebastian Shaw that was just Fox
screwing things up which they're really
known for doing but what you also have
here is you've got a guy by the name of
Donald Pierce now a lot of you guys know
the name from the Logan film the guy who
is basically responsible or at least had
a hand in creating like x-23 and who was
chasing after her and and Wolverine and
so on Donald Pierce eventually goes on
to join the reversed but what none of
the members of the Hellfire Club know
right now is that while Donald Pierce is
part of the Hellfire Club and they are
essentially mutants Donald Pierce hates
mutants and he's actually using a
Hellfire Club as a means to try to like
push his own agenda acquire power unto
himself so he can launch a campaign to
to kill mutants wherever he can find
them now of course ultimately it doesn't
work and Donald Pierce you know being
half machine is cast out and it
eventually joins the Reavers where he's
really been ever since those guys who
were reading the current x-men run
that's really where a lot of that comes
from as it really kind of starts here
but then you also have Harry of Leland
and I always felt like Harry Leland was
one of the most underestimated members
of the Hellfire Club if not one of the
most underestimated characters in Marvel
right like anyway he was so cool and and
no one after Claremont really seemed to
do anything with him so what Harry
Leland Leland can do is he can actually
increase the mass or decrease the mass
of an object around him right so like he
can make Wolverine weigh tons right so
he's like graviton to a degree but he
can
we'll rainway tons right so like neo he
really leaned against the Incredible
Hulk depending on what happens you might
see it play out the exact same way you
saw a graviton and The Incredible Hulk
faced off against each other in the
Avengers cartoon show right we're like
rabbit on just starts increasing the
gravitational pull around the Incredible
Hulk
instead what Leland does is he would
increase the Hawks mass right so if me
if Bruce Banner turns into the Hulk and
he weighs 600 pounds Leland can come
along and say actually you a five
thousand pounds now and just increase it
increases his his mass to an extreme
degree which should actually kind of a
cool fight but you guys understand why
Leland was painfully underestimated in
Marvel and he was painfully under Hughes
it was it was terrible he would make
such a great character in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe right like imagine
that the cares of the MCU I'll end up
showing up to the Hellfire Club and like
suddenly none of them can move and like
they all weigh thousands of pounds they
waste so much that actually they may be
gonna just kind of crush under their own
weight
that's what Leland can do like that's
why he's so awesome but again the x-men
are pretty much taken apart quick fast
and in a hurry by the Hellfire Club the
only exception is well right this is
something I want you guys to notice too
because this is the cool thing about
Claremont rightie
is that when Wolverine fights when he
fights Leland he's basically just like
made away a ton of weight and then
starts crashing through the building
down into the sewer systems and then
Leland walks away that's the way
Claremont would do things and that's
cool because you don't see that in story
arcs now right like Wolverine would show
back up again and fight fight Leland and
then like they would win all in the same
story
Claremont actually extends that to the
next issue and says okay so like
Wolverines defeated right now but like
he's gonna come back and Wolverine by
himself is gonna go rescue Jean Grey now
at the outset and just kind of looking
at this it's just kind of like okay so
Wolverines fighting by himself whatever
but Wolverines fighting for love and
that's one of the cool things that
Claremont had built up that's one of the
reasons why his writing always paid off
is because with Wolverine basically
going back and intending to like rescue
his friends in the x-men that he's doing
it because he's in love with Jean
painfully in love with her right I mean
it's kind of the love triangle between
himself and Cyclops and Jean Grey
so he's going there mainly to rescue her
but to also rescue the other members of
the x-men now the other part of this is
that it really kind of shows this
perception of Jean in terms of how its
viewed from the mind of Jays are from
from her mind by virtue of jason
wyngarde is that where the x-men are
just kind of tied up and they have these
inhibitor belts around them and they
can't use their powers or anything like
that and they're standing in like a
modern-day room and the perception of
jeans
mine they're criminals now they're
basically you know people that tried to
break in they tried to take what belong
to her you know and they're they have to
be dealt with and so on so forth her
whole vision is is skewed and again
that's the nature of jason wyngarde now
a person who's a telepath like Charles
Xavier or person like Jean Grey who
wouldn't be in such a fractured mindset
right now wouldn't normally be able to
oversee this would be normal be able to
like realize what's going on now if this
was like Charles Xavier and Charlie gave
you walked in on this he would be like
what is going on here he would use his
powers and be like Jean you have to see
you know and that would basically be yet
but with Jean Grey's mind being
fractured with like the Phoenix really
sort of just like absorbing and taking
in all these emotional feelings Jean
Grey never had a chance and so that's
kind of the cool thing is because in
this moment in this fraction of a second
where she's basically almost totally
ensnared by by jason wyngarde this
fraction of herself this tiny itty bitty
bring a version of herself which is
still kind of maintaining this psychic
connection with Cyclops it manages a
Cygnus signal to his brain and saying
hey like I'm still here I can't do
anything
I'm totally ensnared like there's
nothing I can really do here I'm almost
totally ensnared I can't escape from
this but you can and in that moment what
ends up happening is the lock or
whatever it is on Cyclops is neck
essentially snaps now this is kind of
the cool thing about that is that when
it snaps and when it breaks it
essentially frees Cyclops right like it
basically allows Cyclops to go free but
this is the end this is the important
thing and this is why this happens and
it's one of the most important moments
throughout the entirety of this story
with Cyclops being held captive Jean
Grey for the most part doesn't care
because it's just this is a guy that's
there it doesn't really matter but
remember ever since the two of them
first met and really Claremont built on
uh built on this is that there's a kind
of psychic bond between Jean Grey and
Cyclops that nobody else has so like no
matter what happens to the other they
are always aware of what's going on with
the other person is really kind of
forged in their love right like they'll
always know what's going on they can
sense when something's off G gray
doesn't have to use her powers to know
she don't have to use her powers to know
there's something wrong with Cyclops the
connection really kind of tells you the
psychic bond weakens
order like it gets it begins to kind of
fracture a little bit when he starts to
get distant that's when we kind of know
that things that things are wrong that
somebody's not working the way it's
supposed to and so with this little bit
of a moment happening the reason why
this works out for works out for Cyclops
the reason why the lock on his neck
snaps and so on is because with the
Phoenix incapacitating Cyclops and with
him fighting against jason wyngarde and
then presumably being killed or at least
jason wyngarde using
powers to make gene believe that Cyclops
has been killed this is the breaking
point because what Jean Grey is
experiencing now is basically the
feeling of loss losing the best thing
she ever knew the one man she's in love
with among every other man in existence
the Phoenix has never felt this before
the Phoenix doesn't know what it's like
to experience the loss of a loved one
someone you're hopelessly in love with
the Phoenix has never experienced that
there's a lot of emotions of Phoenix
hasn't experienced these at the time
this story was written now future
stories came later on down the line they
kind of went back and changed a lot of
this by introducing new things right
like the Phoenix was in love with Odin
and and so on and so forth but at the
time this story's being written the
information that we had the Phoenix had
never experienced any of these things
before and so what's happened here is
the Phoenix it's kind of one with Jean
Grey right like Jean Grey feels loved
the Phoenix feels loved Jean Grey's in
love with Cyclops the Phoenix is in love
with Cyclops you know Jean Grey likes
the x-men the Phoenix likes the x-men
you know Cyclops dies the Phoenix feels
a power of losing someone she loves and
the Phoenix snaps she just loses her
mind like she literally breaks and
that's when all hell begins to break
loose because as soon as that happens
the Phoenix immediately turns on jason
wyngarde and says like i see what you've
been doing now like I get this Rouge
that you've been playing you've been
manipulating me even lying to me you've
been cheating me like you've been
treating me into seeing things that
aren't really there so if what you want
jason wyngarde is to experience the
power of a god then I will give it to
you in its full totality and so the Dark
Phoenix runs up on jason wyngarde and
basically gives him cosmic awareness and
the blink of an eye he sees the entirety
of all things in existence all
throughout the infinite expanse of all
space and time he sees it all at once
and because of that because he's not
prepared for it it's totally
overwhelming now here's the important
thing to bear in mind here as people
will look at that and they'll say yeah
but like ways our Windell Vaughn got
that and it wasn't overwhelming you know
and like viola vels she became like the
new quasar and that wasn't overwhelming
Captain Marvel got that and it wasn't
overwhelming well because it's Marvel is
usually very particular about who gets
it right so it's usually like a slow
build-up to experiencing that so that
kind of level of like cosmic awareness
and being aware of what's going on in
all things at the same time you know
either that or it's someone who kind of
like eases them into it right like when
Wendell Vaughan got that he was eased
into it by the cosmic entity Eon right
he was just kinda like okay so like just
so you know what you're about to see is
gonna be some crazy stuff so just like
breathe and like everything will be okay
but like you're about to see the whole
universe man you know and they would
just like throw it on it
but but you know for this situation
jason wyngarde has never experienced
anything like that so he's blasted with
all existence at the same time which
overwhelms him and actually sends him
into a catatonic state where he will
remain for quite some time
and so in the mall and you'll kind of in
the aftermath of this but the rest of
the x-men basically band together they
manage to make their escape from the
Hellfire Club everything seems okay and
then the Dark Phoenix manifest the dark
mediu Dark Phoenix is totally
overwhelmed by everything she's been
experiencing and it says like Jean Grey
is gone now
there is no Jean Grey there's none of
that stuff I am the Dark Phoenix and all
of you are going to die
well that being said guys we're gonna
bring this video to an end if you are
new here - comments explained make sure
you guys have the sub button to become
part of the Rob pork the guys enjoyed
this video
make sure you drop a like and yeah I
will catch you all later peace
[Music]
[Music]
you